a far majority of this audience could
make between 50 to $100,000 a year just
on doing that for nine to ten hours a
day digital is oxygen it's it's it's the
real world feels secondary if you are
not living through here you are not
known Juanes or get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Gary Vaynerchuk and how to make
more money mentor me Gary
okay let's kick it up with the rule
number one
flip stuff do you understand how crazy
it is that if you went to the clearance
aisles of your five biggest retailers in
Australia bought things on clearance
when home relisted it and posted on ebay
that the far majority of this audience
could make between fifty to a hundred
thousand dollars a year just on doing
that for nine to ten hours a day
meanwhile everybody's sitting here with
the next big app that's gonna be the
next Boober for lawnmowers the thing
that has made me successful far more
than my passion or my energy is my
disproportionate practicality most
people want to look the part of an
entrepreneur that came up with the next
supreme or adidas brand or the next uber
or face book yet our $40,000 in debt
work at a job that they hate and
literally if they went to the five
discount stores that dominate this
market buy things on clearance go home
take a picture with their phone and
upload to ebay and then when people buy
it go to the post office and ship it
they would be able to get out of debt
and get into a financial place but
people don't want to do that because
they don't want to be judged for that
being there hustle most people in this
room and this world would rather lose
looking like they're doing something
successful than win and be judged for
doing something that seems dorky rule
number two
go on in on social in 1996 my dad had a
liquor store in New Jersey
that's as traditional as you get yeah
that was 22 years ago and and I put my
dad's store on online and I did email
marketing and I did Google and I did
content and then a couple months after
YouTube came out I started YouTube show
in 2006 which is now twelve years ago I
I I have no respect or and normally I
deploy a lot of empathy I
struggle deploying empathy I struggle
deploying compassion if you were a
business operator in 2018 headache only
about I'm recording this in October 2019
which is the majority of people gonna
listen to this and you and your excuses
will I'm a pub or I make tomato juice or
I have three restaurants like a digital
is oxygen it's it's it's the real world
feel secondary yeah like to not be a
communicator content producer part of
the conversate it's it's now it's gone
from cute and naive to grossly negligent
you know and I just think it's
unacceptable to be a business in 2019 in
the same way that it would be to pay
people not minimum wage like I literally
believe it's grossly unacceptable like
to me it's like it's like to quantify
digital versus traditional just
marketing like really you think sending
direct mail print is a better thing to
do than advertising on Instagram as a
restaurant like like really like really
sit down with me you're telling me right
now that it's a better deal to spend all
that money making a flier and sending it
the rekt mail yeah or running a radio ad
or buying a small little ad in a
newspaper like this is what you're
telling me
it is 2019 yeah I felt bad in 2002 was
early the internet was new I had
compassion it was cute in 2007 it was
like hmm it was kind of like uh not like
a annoying kind of like hmm it's still
kind of in 2012 like you're not smart in
2019 like you deserve to die also if you
want to learn to have confidence like
gear Ravine other successful
entrepreneurs check out my 254 series
it's free and the link is in the
description below the reason people
don't put themselves in a position to
fail the reason people aren't patient is
they value other people's opinions too
much rule number three maximize your
productivity if you've got debt or have
to put a roof over your head or somebody
else then you work whatever job is
paying you that but I'm asking you what
are you doing from 6 p.m. to midnight
and if you have to go
old slowly your portfolio your Shopify
store your Instagram account your
YouTube channel your content like like
wouldn't you be pumped if I told you for
the next four years it's tough and you
don't watch as much Netflix and Sports
and hanging out but then you get to live
happy for the rest of your life
everybody in theory would sign up for
that the reality is a lot of people
don't want to grind for four years like
people don't like pain it's why most
people don't have six-packs I mean that
I mean that there's a lot of people here
who want to be in better shape you just
don't want to workout you just don't
want to eat well rule number four I
produce digital content please
understand my biggest truth here today
which is if you are not sharing your
thoughts your process your journey your
progress to achieving your goals the
stories you want to tell about your
startup product service if you are not
communicating to the world and if you're
not thinking about what's valuable to
them not what's valuable to you when you
communicate and that is a very big point
I'll say one more time if you are not
communicating to the world and when
you're communicating if you're not
thinking about what's valuable to them
versus what you're putting out for
yourself you are basically irrelevant in
a 20-19 world as much as it may be
difficult for many in this room if you
are not living through here you are not
known this is the game if you are under
estimating this and when I say under
estimating this if you have not made a
significant commitment to producing
content for the one of seven apps or
websites that 80% of this entire region
spends a disproportionate amount of time
penetrating and listening and consuming
you are becoming vastly vastly
irrelevant now I've got a special bonus
clip on doing garage saleing that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action
here we go question number one what can
you flip this weekend in your home
number two how can you go all-in on
social and number three where do you
need to maximize your productivity I
think that garage sale that really turns
me on is the thrill the hunt because
it's the place where you can really
score a huge box of toys for three bucks
worth 300 that much 15 bucks usually
usually truly you only need about a
hundred bucks this could be a visa it
looks a little too new but we're about
the strike they're striking to be done
here
how much gonna stuff the animals
mommy
how much is this
it's alright stuff the animals continue
to be my score 50 cents a pop Dumbo
disneystore
snuffleupagus bang Olaf what and this
one's gonna be a beast the fao schwarz
fao schwarz giraffe so we just looked it
up the the Jeffrey giraffe Toys R Us FAO
Schwartz combo 30 bucks to pay 50 cents
and I'm nice to say after a baby he's
just like a quick 20 bucks just a lot of
people not making 20 bucks an hour
and that's just one of the things wait
till I look up to snuff loveliness
thank you so much this is pretty
exciting to me vintage Lego thing never
opened
now 2003 Jesus I'm getting old but still
15 years old excited to open its up this
was a huge score I already looked it up
paid 3 they wanted 5 paid 3 for these
spider-man skates in package never
opened as well or open pretty excited
about it
don't worry that's the awesome
all right let's go she goes at least go
around the corner for me so good so good
Lego four zero nine eight twenty five
bucks give it to me little
all right pay two bucks for this all
right cool so some may see snow globes
and they are better and I think I
thought
back
you do ten if I bought three you have a
bag I do have a bag this is exciting
we just bought three snow globes for ten
bucks
and I'm fired up I'm fired up my guy
I'm fired up how do you feel feel really
good now just starting to get hot
getting some stuff now well over two
hundred dollar range maybe a little bit
more even
much better
hold on when you need it I like
it says - would you take a balance check
Thanks
I picked up the scary bear for a dollar
called for real from Tiger 2004
let's see what's worth 20 bucks all day
all day 20 bucks
just pick out two jerseys for two bucks
apiece Kevin Durant Seattle SuperSonics
Jersey pretty rare two bucks
Garnett really nice one actually
stitched Celtics two bucks each we'll
say sixty four bucks for the Durant you
know pay two bucks you saw my there's a
little bit like shitty stains on it I
can clean that off just crazy if I was
really doing this right I'd make I'd
make a thousand a week easy and like on
just Saturday just working Saturday so I
mean I genuinely think good will abate
buying bulk on eBay selling and I was
like I just think this is the hundred
thousand dollar-a-year thing there's so
many people making 30 to 60 thousand a
year
I feel phenomenal this is the big final
score it's about a hundred bucks minimum
and now I know about cherished heddes
now much cherished eddie's player and
every time you become more of a player
of a new thing look this is very simple
spent 40 55 20 40 bucks 50 bucks easily
now into the five or six hundred dollar
range of resale I just wish so many of
you would do this it's four or five six
hundred bucks every weekend it's now
1147 so with four hours in
little gas money I get it for like a
net-net
two three four hundred bucks every
weekend and if you don't want to be like
tedious because now you gonna post it
all this cool just wrote this huge
collection of cherished Eddie's 80 bucks
boom quick little you know 60 bucks here
adds up when you got groceries when you
got bills when you got college loans
when you got rent people sitting around
dwelling 85 90 percent this country
working you know minimum wage of low
incomes I think it just matters teaching
people how to fish live life it's real
if you want more gear Evie Chuck at the
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
my ability to only be comfortable in
massive chaos has been my biggest asset
as an entrepreneur like I would never
take a note